proof that tariffs work President Trump
threatened tariffs on Mexico their
leaders came to negotiate and we got
concrete results even the Wall Street
Journal who's generally indispensable
and brilliant editorial pages regularly
rail against terrace recognized the
president's achievement quote in the
course of a week mr. Trump managed to
get Mexico to agree to two things that
months ago would have seemed unlikely
militarized Mexico's crackdown on
migrants by deploying National Guard
troops and expanding the remaining
Mexico Plan for asylum seekers now the
anatomy of this latest tariff dispute
tells us a lot about policy our politics
and government we should learn the
lessons everyone agrees we have a crisis
at the southern border two weeks ago a
thousand illegal immigrants literally
just walked into the country in El Paso
our immigration system is not just
broken for all practical purposes it
doesn't exist but there is one person it
seems who is actually trying to fix it
President Trump that's why he resorted
to his tariff threat it was a new
approach so of course the establishment
lost their minds a five percent tariff
to stop immigration does that make sense
does it make sense part of what the
United States where Trump is asking
Mexico to do what would violate
international law for any of you kids
watching if when you grow up you want to
rattle the financial markets threaten
tariffs against Mexico no offense Brian
but I don't think the kids are watching
your show the Republican establishment
though they hated it too tariffs on the
other hand would be a massive tax I
understand that the president is
frustrated with congressional Democrats
refusing to do their job or to do
anything to fix this crisis that being
said this is the wrong solution to the
crisis there is not much support in my
conference for tariffs that's for sure
the response was knee-jerk ideological
dogmatic so here's the first lesson the
establishment politicians and media
should be more open-minded give new
ideas and new approaches a chance
instead the way they were talking
tariffs on Mexico will be the end of our
economy they let ideology get in the way
of the facts even though Mexico is our
his trading partner is still a tiny part
of our economy imports from Mexico make
up just 1 point 8 percent of our economy
and exports to Mexico are only 1.4
percent it's like the critics didn't
even look at it as a practical policy
question for them it was an article of
faith tariffs are bad it was the same
thing with all their nodding dogs on TV
spouting that line about American
consumers it's gonna cost Mexico that's
gonna cost the car makers no it's gonna
cost consumers the tariffs are taxed
there's no way to describe it other than
it's an overwhelming negative for
American businesses and consumers even I
know
tariffs are a tax that's paid by the
consumer new rule if even joy Reed knows
it's true it's bound to be false now
hang on a second
President Trump has been introducing
tariffs for over two years now going
back to April 2017 when tariffs on
lumber imports from Canada went up to
24% we've had tariffs on China and
Canada on products ranging from steel
and aluminum to toothbrushes and washing
machines and what's happened to consumer
prices in that time we don't have to
guess we have an actual measure it's
called inflation the average inflation
rate for 2016 was 2.1 percent
20:17 2.1 percent 2018 2.4 percent and
2019 so far 1.75 percent it's actually
going down companies don't just sit
there and take it when tariffs are
imposed they respond one person at least
seems to get that he's right companies
are moving away from countries hit by
the Trump tariffs especially China and
in a big way a recent survey by Bain &
Company showed that 25% of corporate
executives who do business in China will
be redirecting their investments out of
the area and 42% of them nearly half are
expecting to source their raw materials
from someplace else
some of the companies leaving China
include verax imaging universal
electronics and GoPro and look at this
quote from the CEO of control tech a
company that used to have a lot of
business in China
quote wheel design China out just think
about that for a moment
there is a massive policy lesson here
for decades the establishment looked on
impotently as American manufacturing
went to China President Trump comes in
imposes tariffs and you see an immediate
private-sector response wheel design
China out Trump's terrace derided by the
snooty Knowles in the establishment are
turning out to be the most consequential
and positive economic policy mechanism
we've seen in decades and it's not just
companies moving out of China we're
seeing the move back to America just as
the president said toy giant Hasbro's
the latest example another thing
establishment geniuses say is that you
shouldn't muddle up trade policy with
immigration policy Senator Chuck
Grassley said trade policy and border
security are separate issues this is a
misuse of presidential tariff Authority
and counter to congressional intent
another Republican Senator James
Lankford was reported as saying that the
administration is trying to use tariffs
to solve every problem but HIV and
climate change but why not has domed
Xiao ping and by the way this is
probably the last time I'm gonna firming
Lee quote a Chinese dictator as dong
Xiao ping said who cares if the cat is
black or white as long as it catches
mice and as we've seen with the Mexico
terrorists it did very quickly president
Trump's use of terrace is an example of
creative entrepreneurial and above all
successful policymaking this was the
whole point of Trump to do things
differently to stand up to all the
useless bureaucrats and naysayers bogged
down in the status quo I can imagine the
meetings on this that the president and
have had the last few months I've been
in those policy meetings oh you can't do
that mr. president you'll upset the
Chinese they hate losing face Oh mr.
president if you do that we'll get
pushed back let's just give the
officials a bit more time to work
something out mr. president talk about
nervous Nancy Pelosi the entire
government machine is stuffed full of
nervous and Nancy's usually the
politicians give in I've seen it over
and over again and that's why nothing
happens but Trump is different imagine
him in those meetings I've had enough of
all your negative crap he might say
something stronger I want action
I want accountability I want results yes
that's what Americans voted for the
establishment idiots who condemned him
for it care about style not substance as
long as you behave the right way say the
right things do it the way it's always
been done they think you're great
regardless of your actual results that's
why they all loved Obama he went along
with it all he behaved the way the
establishment expects Trump doesn't that
doesn't make him bad it makes him good
it's the status quo that's bad the
establishment are obsessed with Trump
and his tweets but he's obsessed with
you
and your life the final big lesson of
this week is of course what's not
happening the president shouldn't be
having to pressurize in Mexico the way
he did it should be our own government
not a foreign government that fixes our
immigration crisis and here we turn to
the Democrats
isn't it sickening to see them on their
high horse about the moral stain of
Trump's border policy on the issue of
immigration
he has also defied who we are morally
and who we say we are to the world
morality it's not who we are as a nation
not who we are
well who are you then Nancy you're
actually the one standing in the way of
the changes that would help prevent the
exact things you complain about let
border officials detained families for
over 20 days let children claim asylum
in their home country and they be
reunited with their families if they're
already here change the asylum threshold
from a credible fear to their likelihood
of actually getting asylum none of this
even has anything to do with a wall that
you Democrats say you hate that of
course we need that too the Democrats
are blocking common-sense immigration
reform purely to score political points
it's you Nancy Pelosi who's exploiting
desperate migrants for political gain
the young girls assaulted on their
dangerous journey the families that are
separated because of our broken system
it's on you Nancy not the evil Trump but
you the person who is actually standing
in the way of solving this problem tell
me what you think at Steve Hilton X and
at next Rev FNC